in the u.s city of portland oregon
black lives matter protesters and
federal law enforcement officials
clashed again overnight
the city's mayor is demanding that the
federal agents be removed
after reports of them driving around in
unmarked cars and seizing
demonstrators off the streets the
federal agents were deployed by
president trump to restore
order after weeks of unrest
they've been on portland streets to
protest racism
every day for more than a month mostly
peaceful
some have clashed with police and
sprayed graffiti on buildings
the trump administration provoked fury
by sending in federal agents
not protecting anyone don't [ __ ]
yourself
officially their job is to protect
federal property like the courthouse
but multiple eyewitnesses report
unidentified officers
far from those buildings forcefully
detaining protesters
they've also used tear gas against the
wishes of local authorities
mr president federal agencies should
never
be used as your own personal army
the words and actions from president
trump and the department of homeland
security
have shown that this is an attack
on our democracy the homeland security
chief has called protesters
violent extremists he's offended using
federal officers including border patrol
agents
and immigration and customs enforcement
in portland
and the president says he's satisfied
with their work
we've done a great job in portland
portland was totally out of control and
they went in and i guess we have many
people right now in jail
and we very much quelled it and if it
starts again we'll quell it again very
easily
the street fights have already turned
political now they're set to become
legal
rights groups are condemning federal
agents for they say
making arrests without probable calls
and the state attorney general plans to
seek a restraining order against them
followed by a federal lawsuit u.s
democratic congressman an icon
of the civil rights movement john lewis
has died he was 80 years old
lewis began his nearly six decade career
in public service fighting against
segregation
in the south he was the last survivor of
the big
six civil rights activists a group led
by the reverend dr martin luther king jr
lewis died after a prolonged battle with
pancreatic cancer
now let's take a look at the latest
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
more than 14 million people have been
infected worldwide and over 580 000 have
died
that's according to the latest figures
from johns hopkins university
the united states has again seen a
record daily number of infections with
over
70 000 people contracting the virus this
friday
texas and florida are currently the
worst affected
and iran's president rouhani says an
estimated 25 million
iranians could be infected with the
coronavirus according to the president
an additional 30 to
35 million people could become infected
in the coming months